how do you say pilgrimage in Arabic
third-grade class in the German city of
Duisburg today's lesson on Islam is
about the pilgrimage to Mecca or Hajj
the children study terms from the Quran
in Arabic and German ogor likes that
because he can tell his German friends
about his faith I tell them that Allah
is Arabic for God and that being in the
mosque is nice 90% of children at this
school come from immigrant families
before the state of North
rhine-westphalia introduced Islam
classes a year ago many of them attended
separate Quran lessons at mosques we
discuss such topics as faith in the
mosque God and the prophets and the
children can express their opinions it's
also our responsibility to correct false
information headmistress Malika's Aetna
vine hard fought for years for the right
to have Islam taught in school she says
it's the right environment for the
subject a systematic kindda i prefer
that children learn about their faith at
a public school instead of at a quran
school because if they go to Aggron
school we don't know what children are
learning there one problem is that
germany faces a shortage of instructors
qualified to teach Islam
Walker's mother picks him up after
school and Mina dockage was born and
raised in Duisburg she likes it that her
son learns about his faith in elementary
school how would your class and religion
good what did you learn today about the
pilgrimage I'm a Muslim myself and I
wanted to continue our tradition so that
he doesn't forget who his parents were
and where they came from but she doesn't
want to send gore to mosque since
everybody there reads the Quran in
Arabic she insists that he learned each
term from the Quran in German he wants
to be able to explain everything
his German friends in school asked him
why do you slaughter animals this way or
why do you fast it's good for him to be
able to talk about that in German Amina
hopes that all Muslim children in
Germany can stay true to their Islamic
faith even while feeling at home in the
country but education is a state and not
a federal policy area in Germany so it
could still be some time before classes
in Islam take hold nationwide